it's bad for him legally I don't know
that it's bad for him politically in
seeking the Republican nomination but if
you read that indictment it's what we
call a speaking indictment so you now
know the evidence that the prosecutors
are going to put into evidence against
him the pictures are there the tapes are
there yeah and it's a strikes me as a
very very strong case he's in big
trouble Legally Legally cuz one of his
attorney generals bar said that he's
toast as far as these uh indictments are
yeah I hate to agree with Bill bar but I
on this on this I will that I think
anybody who cares to understand it after
reading it will understand he's in big
trouble and because he though you said
you mentioned the difference between uh
legal trouble and political trouble
because he's saying that even if
indicted even if charged even if
convicted he's still going to run as
president is that is that possible under
the American Constitution it is being
convicted of a felony might actually
prevent him from voting for himself but
it doesn't it does not prevent it it
does not prevent him from being a
candidate for office yeah now and I
should one less thing for him to think
about isn't it right a lot on his plate
yes yeah but it's a yeah we're in such
if you wrote this in a screenplay it
would get rejected that that the
Republican Party might nominate such a
person but I think they might oh I'm so
glad I'm not writing vep at the moment
because so much of what's Happening Now
is but that there he is gaining momentum
and traction and you know turning it
into Donald Trump show by saying there's
no evidence they've got nothing on me
while pictures of classified documents
in boxes in his bathroom have been
released and we're at that stage CU I
mentioned the Hillary Clinton email
thing we'll get on to that that seemed
so important and and you know people
people were getting very very worked up
about it at the time that she might have
used emails or sent emails on a personal
server rather than this is the nuclear
codes sitting in his
shower and yet why hasn't the world
caved in what's what's happened in those
four or five years to to to turn that
climate into one where the reality is
not something that people take seriously
cuz it's as to his supporters which are
a distinct minority of Americans it's
not about facts they've been drawn into
a cult really and and so there's no way
out for them and every bad fact is
painful for them if they stare at it and
so they turn away January 6th the TV
Whispers to them you fool look what you
did you fool very few people can stare
at that most turn away I've had cases
where fraud victims showed up to support
the fraud St sentencing because it's so
hard to admit about yourself that that I
was a fool and so there are millions of
Americans for whom it doesn't matter
what you just said is absolutely true
about the difference between this and
the Clinton case it doesn't matter
because it's not about the facts for
those folks and so there's nothing
really to be done about that slice of
his followers they'll drift away
eventually write another story just as
ni when Nixon resigned 30 some per
supported him but they found a way to
drift away from him and that that's what
it'll take with that hardcore group but
will they drift away in time for the
next election or is there still a a real
danger that I think there a real a real
prospect that he will be the Republican
nominee for president I think it is very
unlikely that the American people in
Even in our slightly odd electoral vote
system would elect Donald Trump but it's
a nonzero chance which is why it's so
important the American people focus on
what's going to be on the ballot next
year and in a way they're not going to
be able to avoid focusing because he'll
be front and center in our lives again
MH talk front Etc I mean you've met the
guy up close uh most notoriously at a
was a dinner or a lunch where he sat you
down and asked you as head of the FBI to
go easy to lay off like a you you
mentioned it's it's like the language of
a mobster really that that sense of go
easy on my guys you know keep them you
know that's bad bad stereotype Italian
mafia New York
just just I I actually I'm going to make
a complaint against myself for that
sorry but
but but what I mean talk us through that
moment then you know when you're up
close with something like well that was
actually the the so-called loyalty
dinner we were sitting as close as you
and I are alone they had pushed all the
furniture off to the side of this
cavernous Green Room on the ground floor
the base the first floor excuse me of
the Residence at the White House why
what I don't know why gigantic rug with
a tiny table and we faced each other and
he asked for directly asked me to
promise loyalty to him and I was so
surprised by it all I could think to do
was stare at the man and so one beat two
beats three beats of silence and then he
looked down and started eating again and
came back to it but the purpose of that
dinner was for me to promise him that I
was his FBI director and so I didn't
Focus much on the food because the rest
of the time I was trying to make sure
that I didn't say anything that would
reinforce that idea do you think uh I
mean there were no notes Tak would there
be notes taken at that launch or would
you take notes afterwards the moment I
got in my armored car I started writing
down everything that had been said okay
because I knew how significant that was
and I knew that it was the really the
end between the two of us because I
wouldn't give him what he wanted and it
wasn't just the stare but I to to tell
Donald Trump anything you almost always
have to interrupt him and so I
interrupted him to tell him here's how
it has to work why it's so important to
have the department Department of
Justice have an independent Spirit from
the president the American people have
wanted it for 50 years since Jer Hoover
and he was focused on his ice cream or
something so it didn't get through what
when you say you had to interrupt him is
is that what he's like then is it just
is it a kind of uh long flow of any word
that comes into his head what's the yeah
it's a long again in my experience it's
a long verbal search for affirmation so
he's just constantly telling you things
and then saying right I'm right about
that I'm right about that and probably
the tensest moment that we had was he
was trying to get me sitting in the Oval
Office to agree that what he had said
about Putin was fine when he had said
you know America we're Killers too and
and I wouldn't agree and I said Mr
President actually I think that's wrong
and that's that's not a good description
of the way we conduct ourselves and it
was almost like a shadow across the room
at that moment and so I was surprised
the day I was fired I shouldn't have
been surprised to be fired were you
where how did you get the news I was
talking to employees in the Los Angeles
field office and I was a big audience of
FBI people and behind in this training
room there were three televisions with
no sound on tuned to news
channels and while I'm speaking I start
to
notice that and the first one that pic
it it's I have to relive this right now
unfortunately but it we' got the TV
monitors here but just it said over on
the TVs it said Comey
resigns yes and so I I you all don't
know this but there's a lot of very
funny people in the FBI and so I thought
it was a practical joke and so I turned
to the head of the LA office a woman
that I had promoted who I thought the
world of and I said that took a lot of
work and then I kept talking and then
the cuz I wasn't going to let them get
the better of me so I wanted to be a
good sport but I so I kept talking and
then I noticed it now said Comey fired
across all of them and I thought n
they're not going to go
there and so now all the employees are
turning around looking at the screens
and I said look I don't know whether
that's true or not I'm going to go find
out but it doesn't change what I want to
say to you and so I said some things
about about the quality of their work
and then I walked out you you you could
have maintained the uh the lie you
should you could have taken a queue from
your president just like that didn't
happen there was all lies fake news
mainstream media didn't happen I'm still
here I wish you'd been there I'm not
going to leave
um and and there and did you get a a
leaving pres present or did you uh I did
not uh I I was allowed to fly home on
the FBI aircraft uh which infuriated
Trump he called uh my Deputy who
immediately became the acting director
and said he wanted an investigation as
to how I was allowed to come home on an
FBI plane and the deputy said like I
could investigate it but I can tell you
the answer right now I I authorized
it we're responsible for his protection
we can't leave him in
LA and but the the uh Trump was Furious
about that yeah see that is an episode
of succession I think I
think I think one of the Roy takes a
plane and uh another Roy
says he's not allowed to do that but
actually the the the the resign behind
you I think we did do that in the thick
of it we didn't do it in V but we did do
Malcolm Tucker says he's not resigning
and then but the news comes on right
behind him um it's funny now it's funny
yeah yeah what were I mean but you said
but actually when you had the lunch you
kind of thought that is it though didn't
you that that the you know you know that
the tide has turned and and yeah when I
wouldn't I mean the purpose of that was
to to extract a promise from me that I
would be no threat to him or any of his
people and then when I wouldn't agree to
dump the case against Michael Flynn that
was the second Stone in the load and
then the third I think was when I
interrupted him to tell him he was wrong
about Putin and America and then the
fourth was he wanted me to say publicly
he wasn't under investigation and I
wouldn't do it and
so I and here's the way I misinterpret
it I thought he hates me good because
that means there'll be a distance
between us he won't be inviting me over
for dinner anymore but it tipped over
into sort of an irrational I need to get
rid of this
guy